all right big cat it's the friday
tradition in season who is under the
most pressure this weekend in the nfl
trivia question determines the first
pick you have the question and hopefully
i'll have the answer okay patrick
mahones was injured last night and will
likely miss at least one game
who is the last reigning mvp to miss a
game
the last reigning mvp to miss a game
you know
this is one of those that i should know
and i
i don't know i i guess i should just
pull out a name tom brady
nope
cam newton 2016. i thought you would get
that one
yeah uh yeah i don't know uh i can't
because
yeah okay uh i didn't i never think i'm
gonna get these right i would be
horrible on jeopardy i love watching
jeopardy i would be horrible on it
because when that clocks on you got four
seconds i can't think of the answer it
has no i wouldn't have gotten that one
if you'd give me 10 minutes though it
has nothing to do with the fact that you
have rocks for brains right
that may have something there may that
may be a factor go ahead and make your
first pick all right my first pick it's
going to be an easy one i'm gonna say
dan quinn i think he could get fired
after this game mike i honestly do i
know you were saying that he'll he won't
he'll make it to the bye week in two
weeks if the rams
get right in atlanta on sunday
and we have another defensive
performance like they had against the
cardinals last week where
david johnson and kylo murray were just
ripping off big play after big play
i would i would not be shocked if dan
quinn is fired on monday morning the uh
the old jay gruden come into the office
at 5am so i can kick you out the door so
i'm gonna have dan quinn as my guy the
most under pressure he's probably he's
fired regardless but
if he can win this game he at least will
probably last the rest of the season i'd
say
but you're talking yourself out of the
notion that he's under pressure because
my reaction to you is he's not under
pressure because we know it's over
there's no
pressure you don't want to get fired
coach no you don't want to get fired
mid-season there's an extra level of
embarrassment there and you you don't
want to have that happen and so i think
if you mike whether whether you know
you're going to get fired regardless or
not like going into sunday he knows that
if things go really bad he's fired in a
matter of hours that's pressure
but then he doesn't have to worry about
his old team coming to town the next
weekend the seahawks and kicking the
crap out of him i mean i think if you
sense it's already over at the end of
the season why not just get it over with
now so i can make plans for next year
and i can get you know there's a point
where i think it it feels so
dysfunctional and it's so disruptive and
it's driving you crazy it's a relief
factor if and when you finally get out i
bet jay gruden is relieved that he got
out of washington not that atlanta is
nearly as dysfunctional but i just feel
like there's a point where the pressure
is so great the pressure goes away it's
like you're isn't your theory that the
surface of the sun is cool right it's
kind of like that
yeah that's not the theory but okay
i thought i thought this the the the
theory is why it's cold i thought that's
something
if the sun is hot why is space cold
we know that the surface of the sun is
is hot but why is space cold okay you
screw it up don't try to do my jokes
because you always screw them up
all right uh i screw up every joke so i
may as well try to do yours at least
people will understand what i'm talking
about maybe jason garrett's under the
most pressure this weekend by far
because it's still it's still in the
balance for him it can still go
uh finish the season and get yourself
another contract he can still salvage
this and he did it last year he operated
very well under a very similar set of
circumstances three and five going into
philadelphia sunday night football if
they lose an ugly fashion he could be
fired all of that's out there now and
you've got
jerry jones who supports him completely
and totally until the moment that he no
longer does he can roll out of bed any
given day and say jason it was fun but
see you later so i think he is under the
most pressure by far going into this
weekend's games
okay um all right my next book that's
good pick i had that as well
i think my guy matt nagy i think he's
under some pressure this week because
it's a bye week you gotta the offenses
looked terrible you're hoping that they
come back you know they made some
adjustments on the offensive line kyle
longwin on the ir
they want to be able to run the ball
it's going to be tough against the
saints last year the bears lost after
the bye week to the dolphins even though
that was a clear mac got injured and the
whole game kind of fell apart there but
i think there's a little bit of pressure
on matt nagy to have a strong
performance with mitch trubisky coming
off the buy and put a lot of bears fans
in chicago
at ease that this season is still okay
and they still have everything in front
of them
who's under more pressure between naggy
and trubisky i guess if you thought it
was trubisky he'd have been your pick
but it feels like they're kind of both
in the same spot but but naggy is also
you know it's it's how the bears came
out so flat in london that
that's kind of when a team comes out
that flat i put it on the head coach
most the time like the head coach has to
find a way to get the team up to play 60
minutes and not show up at in the second
half and hope you can win the game so
the first quarter of this game on sunday
if the bears look flat again then
there's an issue then there's a big time
problem so i think for for tomorrow for
sunday's game it's matt nagy for you
know obviously the future of mitch
briske's under pressure
we mentioned mike vrabel's name earlier
in the program and i think mike rabe is
a great coach and i think he will be a
great coach but i also know this since
jeff fisher completed his 17-year run
with the houston oilers tennessee oilers
tennessee titans they have been rotating
coaches out quickly it was mike munsheck
to ken wisenhunt to mike malarkey his
reward for finishing in the final eight
was to get fired from mike frable and
now look at where the titans are because
they they set the bar
high by beating the browns by 30 points
to start the season and since then
they're one in four they haven't won a
home game the browns win isn't as
impressive in hindsight as it seemed at
the time the win over the falcons not
nearly as impressive as it seemed at the
time they got the chargers coming to
town this week
if they lose this one
i think mike grebel has to start
worrying about a titan's ownership group
that has been very fickle with coaches
deciding that maybe we made a mistake
and maybe we need to reset more than
just the quarterback position for 2020.
i hope it doesn't happen and i love mike
frable as a coach but you have to factor
in the titans they're not quite
washington level dysfunction but there
has been some dysfunction there in
recent years and i think vrabel needs
more than two years to to get rid of all
of it but he may not get that especially
if he can't beat a chargers team that
suddenly is among the worst in the nfl
on sunday at home okay so there you go
perfect segue mike way to throw it up to
me uh the chargers the other side of
that game i think the chargers are under
pressure because we've heard it year in
and year out the chargers have a
talented roster of course they have
injuries because they are the chargers
it feels like they start the season with
three pro bowlers injured but this is a
big game for them because they're going
in to nashville against the titans team
that's not very good on their second
quarterback if the chargers lose this
game that's it for the season i think
there you know it's it probably is
already it but it's it's really it if
you lose this game to the titans i think
the charges are under a lot of pressure
because what's the future going to look
like they have again a talented roster
but what's the future going to look like
if the chargers falter on a season when
everyone sort of thought they were going
to be in the mix for the afc playoffs
and one of those teams that could
contend for the afc championship
and they were just so lifeless on sunday
night you know some teams step up in
prime time the steelers seem to always
do it the chargers at home and you know
you could say well it was all steelers
fans they're used to playing in a
stadium that is overrun by fans of the
visiting team they just had no juice
they had no energy and it was obvious
from the first five minutes of the game
that they were not going to be able to
win all right last one for me
and
this this takes us back to last friday
when we spent so much time criticizing
pat shurmur the giants head coach for
punting on fourth and two from his own
33 with 708 to play down 14 points
one of the points we made when
criticizing that move is at some point
people are going to realize
that pat shurmur may be the problem with
the giants there's been so much well
it's eli well it's dave gettleman well
it's john mara well at some point maybe
it's pat shurmur and you have the
arizona cardinals coming to town a team
that should not beat the giants the
giants should be able to win this game i
don't care that the cardinals have won
two in a row they've beaten two of the
worst teams in the nfl the giants have
hung tough tougher than the final score
would suggest 28 to 10 and 35 to 14 with
teams that are better than them this is
a game the giants have to win or
schermer is going to begin to become the
focal point of the criticism and i think
more people are going to start wondering
whether or not he's the right guy for
this team moving forward and yeah
they have to win it because depending on
who wins on sunday night the giants are
now going to be tied for second place if
they win this game on sunday so
that changes the whole scope of the
giants season i agree with you and pat
shurmur i was saying this i was
preaching this before
daniel jones came in it felt like eli
manning was a shield for him and no one
really questioned pat sherman and
whether he was a good coach because eli
manning was getting trotted out there
every single week and being kind of a
walking corpse so now that it's daniel
jones now that you have a winnable game
at home and the division has fallen back
to you this is a big game for him that's
a good pick mike i actually you know
what
i'm gonna say it mike
you have finally beaten me in a draft
you did it you did it wow yeah that is a
good point by you
that is an excellent point you've got
quick
charges wait
no never mind i'm looking at the picks
now i won all right i got jason garrett
mike for one patch trimmer i won i i you
listen in that moment of clarity you
spoke the truth for one
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports